welcome to viewers around the world i'm
pierce morgan and i'm uncensored
as nelson mandela might have said it's
been a long walk to freedom of speech
but now i'm back with a nightly forum
for fabulous guests fearless debate and
yes some fun in fact just before we came
on air tonight i received a wonderfully
sincere good luck message from the
world's funniest man
the producers of piers morgan's new show
contacted me and asked me if i'd like to
be a guest i said definitely not
they said would you mind doing a quick
video wishing him luck i said do i have
to mean it they said no i said good luck
but first i want to issue an urgent
trigger warning
[Music]
for all ultra-sensitive permanently
offended woke snowflakes who may have
accidentally tuned in tonight you're not
going to enjoy this show in fact it's
going to really annoy you it may even
provoke trauma because i'm gonna be
constantly celebrating the one thing you
can't abide free speech and that's real
free speech not your kind of free speech
well only your opinions are allowed and
anyone with a different opinion has to
be shamed abused and cancelled their
careers and reputations destroy
no the free speech is supposed to be the
bedrock of any real democratic society
the kind where it's okay to disagree
it's all right to respect and tolerate
each other's views it's even okay to go
for a beer with someone you've just
spent a whole hour arguing with about
the burning issues of the day
many great people have said many great
things about free speech so winston
churchill said some people's idea of
free speech is that they are free to say
what they like but if anyone says
anything back that is an outrage
president george washington said if
freedom of speech is taken away then
dumb and silent we may be led like sheep
to the slaughter but my all-time
favorite came from the brilliantly
fearless provocative of much missed
polenis is christopher hitchens who said
my own opinion's enough for me anyone
who disagrees with this can pick a
number get in line and kiss my ass
my sentiments exactly
nobody's getting cancelled on piers
morgan on sensor this is a no-cancel
zone
[Music]
no opinion will be silenced no debate
will be off limits no bs will be
tolerated and yes if it's all right with
you we're going to enjoy ourselves i
couldn't put it better than my late
great friend the australian cricket
genius shane warne one of the world's
most iconic sportsmen
and in this politically correct day and
age we've just got to be a little bit
careful but sometimes
just say get stuff to the fun police
well said shane
you heard the man fun police get stuffed
my mission statement for this show is
very simple i'm going to cancel cancel
culture i'll defeat this insidious
joyless societal scourge with those most
effective of democracy preserving
weapons common sense and truth and
that's the truth by the way not your
truth and definitely not princess
pinocchio's truth
i'll always fight your corner i'll
always have your back well unless you're
a liberal liberals who want to wreck
anyone with an opinion that you've ruled
as offensive or cancelled crusaders
rewriting history as one great sopping
apology conducting the banish
inquisition sailing the internet on your
purity purge stamping your extremist
views on the rest of the world with no
tolerance for any discussion or debate
or ideological imperialist waving your
digital snitch forks hounding good men
and women out of their jobs and
reputations because they tweeted
something you didn't like
or hypocrite celebrities participating
about equality from their massive
mansions and constantly preaching one
thing while doing the complete opposite
themselves i think you know the time
right your royal highness
or trans trojans engulfing the internet
in your flames of rage when women dare
to say things like women exist
or internet excavators raking over
ancient social media profiles in search
of fossilized evidence that someone you
disagree with wasn't mother teresa
or prevaricating politicians who lie
cheap break the law and blunder without
accepting accountability
or vegan virtue signals you want to make
mincemeat out of people like me for
eating steak without seeing the irony
the one common trait of all these people
is insufferable self-righteousness they
don't just think they're right they know
they're right and anyone who said
otherwise must be destroyed
well i've got some breaking news for you
tonight
nobody's right all the time not even me
although my record is admittedly better
than most it's okay to be wrong
it's a right to evolve your opinions
when facts change whether you live in
britain america or australia it's time
you went back to being real democracies
silencing censoring no platforming and
cancelling people who disagree with you
isn't democratic or liberal it's
actually a form of modern day fascism
which of course they profess to hate
i've always loudly and proudly stood up
for civil rights women's rights gay
rights and trans rights i always will i
believe in fairness and equality for
everybody but that hasn't stopped the
work brigade branding me racist sexist
homophobic and transphobic and that's
some of the nicer things they call me
all abusively spewed from people with
that disingenuous be-kind hashtag in
their twitter bios there's nothing kind
about these awful people not any room
for logical reason in their perverse
world of liberal authoritarianism
these are dangerous times for
democracies built on free speech
we've regressed thousands of years back
to the days when warring tribes of
people who look the same sounded the
same dressed the same and thought the
same marched around spears out paying
for the blood of anyone remotely
different to themselves
and i've reached a very unfortunate
conclusion
i mean it has right but statues of
churchill
mandela
and gandhi all have to be boarded up at
london's parliament square because woke
imbeciles might trash them for being
problematic
when tall powerful formerly male trans
athletes are smashing records in women's
sport
when pregnant men get an emoji but women
are called birthing people
when snow white's prince is a sexual
predator because for that kiss he didn't
ask for consent
and when mr potato head has had his
actual nuts removed
night after night i'll highlight this
nonsense for what it is nonsense because
the world has gone nuts and not even a
global pandemic or a war in europe
you've just snapped us all out of it
so let piers morgan uncensored be your
island of sanity your department of
common sense the last refuge of the
slant we're global we're going to annoy
all the right people and i'm uncensored